guys we're see if brain baseball caps
come back and style so the question is
should you bend it or should you leave
it flat I'm here with the legendary Don
C designer of just enhance so let's talk
a little bit about the virtues of the
flat brim first I mean to me it's that
it starts with that just it looks
brand-new right
that's what it is it's like you're a
brand new crispy white t-shirt when you
first get the Hat
you want to be delicate with it because
you know it's brand new right it still
has that brand new car smell on the
inside and you throw it on and the
visors flat to me always feel like it's
a rapper vibe right right a flat brim
you know I feel like gee when I wear I
feel like a clean crisp eg right when
I'm wearing a flat brim but then when I
want to show that I'm a real person and
kind of get my kicks dirty or I'm going
to the grocery store I bend it a little
bit or Binger gangster just a little bit
all right then let's talk about the bent
broom a little bit cuz to me that's for
the guy who like lights the broken in
boots you know he likes his ripped up
jacket likes his ripped up jeans like
you're wearing today
you know the Leo style is always fresh
you know it's kind of incognito when you
at the airport for the bedroom I think
of like baseball players I looked up to
oh yeah
Dale Murphy and he wear like the same
couple hats all season long 162 games so
that's what I've been doing to the sweat
marks broken-in kind of disgusting
looking yep and then it perfectly looks
like worn like your 1974 Atlanta Braves
that gotta earn it so it does seem like
in the in the past couple months there
have been more guys spending their
Bryn's again
any thoughts on like where that might
come from you know people want to evolve
their own personal style and I'm seeing
a lot of rappers lately due to bent brim
which to me is like an anti rapper look
right so I think this guy's just trying
to like you know do something different
and individually like express you know
their style so guys back home check out
whatever your friends are doing and do
the opposite that's the way to go it's
the cool way right
do the flat brim is like straight-up
gangsta s it's like the straight-up G
and then you hear who your bent rim is
just leaning right and kind of floating
in your cholo 64 Impala hidden searches
I'm just gonna love it